this is the Terracotta Army  eight thousand warriors buried over two  thousand years ago one of the greatest  wonders of the world  this is the first Emperor's army he  ordered his real army to be recreated in  clay and buried with him ready to fight  his battles in the afterlife each faces  individual unique look at the scale this  place does he a lot about the guy was he  go his vision for his afterlife no what  I experienced  these Warriors are set for battle  exactly like the Emperor's real army  light infantry at the front then heavy  infantry an even cavalry at the rear  five hundred and twenty life-sized  horses it's a really incredible feeling  to be here standing in a place where  nobody really gets access I mean we're  at the center at the heart of this  unbelievable World Heritage Site which  is in a lot of ways the symbol of my own  cultural heritage my ancestry